il faut avoir en tête que concevoir une
telle infrastructure opérationnelle dans
des délais aussi courts
c'est c'est un enjeu auquel une
administration dea confronté que de
manière très épisodique et j'ai envie de
dire heureusement
or c'est une typologie de projets que
nous conduisons régulièrement juste pour
vous donner une idée sur les six
dernières années nous sommes intervenus
dans la reconfiguration de quelque chose
comme 700 chaîne logistique mondiale et
donc c'est cette expertise la voilà qui
nous a permis de donner moi de vous
interrompre un instant mais ça s'est
justifié par le fait qu'il y avait
beaucoup de lieux de distribution
docteur variés pour effectuer la
vaccination
mais ce choix et c'est un choix qui a
été fait de ce type de distribution de
vaccins on a vécu une autre situation
2009 2010 où le monde l'épisode 2 de
grippe h1n1 ont chois avait été
radicalement différent est entièrement
gérée par l'administration de ce pays de
faire de ce qu'on appelait des
vaccinodromes entre guillemets donc
est-ce que vous avez participé à la
décision enfin en tout cas pas par votre
expertise par des éléments vous auriez
amené à l'administration pour faire ce
choix de ne pas reproduire le schéma
vaccinodromes de la grippe h1n1 pour un
choix de des fusions beaucoup plus
complexe à gérer
merci monsieur le président alors pour
être vraiment très clair là dessus parce
que beaucoup de choses ont été dus nous
n'aurons été dit nous n'avons pas eu de
rôle dans la définition de la stratégie
vaccinale en tant que tel notre rôle a
été dans l'opérationnalisation des choix
dans la logistique finalement bienvenu
dans l'opérationnalisation de tous les
toutes les décisions et toutes les
actions qui ont suivi ces choix là et
donc les choix tels que qui vacciner
dans quel ordre quel vaccin utilisé
qu'elles devaient être les lieux de
vaccination quel effecteur devait être
mobilisé dans ces voix là les décisions
sur le pass vaccinale les actions de
communication tous ces éléments là
étaient exclus de notre périmètre
d'intervention
donc ça c'est vraiment important de
le préciser
et du coup ce que ce que nous avons fait
très concrètement c'est d'appuyer
d'appuyer la tasse force
interministériel sur trois trois volets
1 le cadrage opérationnelle et la mise à
l'échelle de ces flux logistiques et est
donc ça a été un appui à la mise en
oeuvre de pilotes puis de test à
l'échelle puis des différents schémas
logistiques eux
voilà et puis ensuite la construction
d'outils de pilotage qui permettent un
ajustement en continu de manière à
s'assurer que la qualité de service soit
au rendez-vous et qu'elles suivent
l'évolution l'évolution de la campagne
à titre d'exemple un des enjeux qu'on a
eu en préparation de l'été c'était
d'anticiper les flux et les déplacements
de la population pendant les périodes de
vacances pour nous assurer que les
vaccins soient là où se trouve la
demande
pendant pendant l'été donc on a eu tout
au long de la campagne des séries 2
voilà deux sujets très opérationnelle à
gérer donc ça c'est le premier élément
sur le pilotage des flux ensuite nous
sommes mobilisés pour mettre en place et
accompagner les processus et les outils
de coordination de la campagne est donc
au départ de définir et donc là vraiment
dans une logique de gestion de projet de
définir les rôles et responsabilités
afin que les centaines d'actions qui
devait être mené en parallèle le soin
et soit instruite comme il se devait et
puis ensuite la mise en place du
processus de suivi de manière à ce qu'on
puisse identifier très tôt ou est ce
qu'il y avait éventuellement des
déviations et des mesures correctives
collective à apporter et puis dernier
point sur le benchmarking est donc une
cartographie on ait un suivi en continu
de l'avancement des campagnes de
vaccination dans d'autres pays à la fois
pour éclairer les choix qu'ils avaient
été pris et puis pour comparer
l'avancement de la campagne française à
ce qui se passait à l'international
la crise sanitaire vous avez également
une mission en janvier 2021 pour la mine
l'aide à la mise en place d'une tour de
contrôle stratégique auprès de santé
publique france c'est soir mans pour un
montant de 650 euros d'après les
informations que nous avons recueillies
vous avez participé à la mise en place à
l'animation de brief quotidien
transverses interne à santé publique
france 2 fois par jour à 9 heures et à
15 heures est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi consistaient
concrètement cette mission s'il vous
plaît bien sûr et search monsieur le
président en a assez vite en fait dès
les premières semaines de la campagne il
est apparu que santé pluie de france
avait un rôle absolument central et
qu'un grand nombre des actions et des
activités tomber sous leur
responsabilité
et tout ça avec encore une fois des
enjeux de délai
qui se mesuraient en heure plus tôt
quand
en jours en semaines et dans un contexte
de tensions fortes sur les ressources de
spf tout simplement du fait de la grande
quantité d'activités qui étaient à gérer
en parallèle dans des délais extrêmement
courts et donc c'est le ministère qui
nous a demandé ouais je pense que madame
chaîne l'avait précisé lors de son
audition qui nous a demandé de venir
mobiliser un appui complémentaire auprès
de spf
pour effectivement appuyé ces travaux de
coordination extraordinairement intense
et j'insiste sur le côté absolument
exceptionnel de la situation
et donc il s'agissait de conduire des
revues on a conquis ont été appelés des
revues d'anticipation
est donc là plusieurs fois par semaine
c'était un travail pour anticiper
identifié anticiper les problématiques
ou les sujets qu'ils pouvaient engendrer
des risques opérationnels sur sur les
activités de spf et le schéma est donc
quelques exemples c'est comment est-ce
qu'on s'assure d'anticiper la montée des
cadences de livraison sur les capacités
de stockage à -80 il ya moins 20 sur la
capacité de transport et la nature des
transports nécessaires sur la capacité
des établissements pivot qui ont un joué
un rôle clé dans un certain nombre des
flux logistiques enfin voilà et donc
donc s'assurer que à chaque fois qu'une
décision était prise au niveau
ministériel on prenait en compte toutes
les implications potentielles qui risque
est posée poser des difficultés ce tour
de contrôle stratégie en fait c'est une
déclinaison de questions de logistique
que vous avez que vous aviez alors la
tour de contrôle qui a été mis en place
effectivement au sein de spf était une
tour de contrôle en tout cas c'est le
terme qui avait été retenu
spécifiquement pour suivre aiguille est
tous les aspects logistiques qu'il
s'agissait bien de quelque chose de très
opérationnelle
de manière à coordonner encore une fois
l'ensemble des actions
qui était qui étaient en cours et donc
on parle au fond
d'une fonction de gestion de projet et
voilà et et là encore pour vous donner
quelques exemples du type de sujets sur
lesquels cette tour de contrôle
permettait de s'assurer que encore une
fois les problématiques était anticipée
et puis tous les aléas
qui se produit a été gérée dans des
délais qui permettait d'assurer la bonne
qualité de service
c'était sur les flux amont donc dans
l'approvisionnement des dispositifs
médicaux notamment de pouvoir réagir si
un avion était bloqué si un fournisseur
avait un retard dans les livraisons
comment est ce qu'on anticipait ont géré
cette situation comment est ce que dans
les flux aval
on traitait les aléas dans les
livraisons dans les excursions de
température éventuellement donc c'est
tour de contrôle elle était là pour
s'assurer de la coordination et de la
gestion encore une fois dans des délais
extrêmement courts avec des engagements
de des enjeux de qualité de service
important
pour faire en sorte que que le résultat
soit soit au rendez vous et à côté de
cette mission sont qu'un de vos
collaborateurs a été mis à disposition
de spf et du ministère de la santé pour
assurer la coordination opérationnelle
sur le volet logistique
approvisionnement distribution des
vaccins ce qui a l'air d'être un peu le
sujet que vous venez d'évoquer pour la
tour de contrôle est cette personne
qualifié d'agent de liaison a fait
l'objet d'une facturation pour cent
soixante dix mille euros lors comment
est-ce que ça s'articule avec le marché
précédent oui et en fait l'articulation
c'est fait c'est fait dans le temps dans
un premier temps effectivement le
ministère nous a demandé de venir
appuyer cette coordination
extraordinairement intense à partir de
la mi-décembre
et c'est cette fonction-là qui a été
appelé
agent de liaison et donc ça c'était
vraiment de s'assurer que
ce que je parlais ce dont je parlais
tout à l'heure sur l'anticipation et sur
la coordination d'actions qui étaient
prises au sein du ministère des ae res
de santé plus vite france et et de voilà
de s'assurer que cette coordination là
soient bien en place dans un deuxième
temps à partir de janvier excusez moi
monsieur vous ne pensez pas qu'il y
aille au sein de notre administration et
particulièrement de notre haute
administration des fonctionnaires qui
pourraient remplir ses missions et
notamment celle d'agent de liaison ça me
paraît quand même assez
étonnant qu'on puisse faire appel à un
cabinet conseil pour faire la liaison
entre de
jeu merci madame la rapporteure jeu mais
je m'attarderai pas sur le terme d'
agent de liaison qui voilà qui dont on
pourrait interroger mais encore une fois
cette année
ses sites et de coordonner à des miles à
l'heure
près une série d'activités très complexe
en parallèle
à nécessiter encore une fois en
complément toutes les ressources qui
étaient déjà mobilisés et encore une
fois dans un contexte de tension sur les
ressources
de permettre de délivrer la qualité de
service mais peut-être madame la
rapporteure pour aussi compléter ce
point la réponse est oui mais il faut
pour voir un peu le contexte c'est que
nous avons été appelés tout début
décembre il fallait réagir très vite
nous avons fait ce rôle de manière
temporaire ensuite nous notre rôle a été
ensuite de faire monter une équipe
dédiée qui a repris l'ensemble de ces
tâches et nous nous sommes désengagés
malheureusement la crise devait
s'amplifier
nous l'espérons pas bien évidemment
chacune et chacun
il n'y aurait toujours pas au sein de
l'administration des personnels pour
assumer ses missions
madame le rapporteur là nous noterons
messine de la question comment oui mais
moi je vais vous dire aussi notre rôle c
on a été appelé début décembre il a
fallu mobiliser pendant l'ensemble des
vacances de noël une équipe d'une
vingtaine de personnes pour permettre au
lancement mais c'est ça le prend ensuite
nous et nous le disons c'est pas notre
rôle et je les dis dans mon propos
liminaire d'exercer de manière durable
ses missions donc notre rôle a été
ensuite de faire monter de construire
une équipe qui ensuite au père est très
dans la durée et pour répondre à votre
question oui madame il faut que la santé
la capacité à déployer des équipes pour
faire face à ça je voudrais revenir sur
sur les explications données par
monsieur long sur ces deux missions
je vais très très simplement si de
reformuler pour mettre à l'épreuve ce
que j'ai compris de ce que vous avez
voulu dire
il ya une première mission en quelque
sorte une préfiguration
et elle savait insuffisante en
dimensionnement et on enchaîne on
continue avec chose d'un peu plus
robustes tels que la tour de contrôle
c'est à peu près ça sous votre contrôle
mais à ce moment là il faut m'expliquer
comment tout ça est compatible avec le
système de tourniquet dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est à dire vous êtes
appelé successivement deux fois pour des
missions alors que j'avais compris moi
que dans le cadre de l'accord cadre sa
tournée le principe du tourniquet
monsieur le président c'est que quand il
ya une continuité de projet
le cabinet demeure parce que il faut
aussi vis-à-vis de l'administration ne
pas faire des ruptures de charge je
pense que ça aurait été assez
inexplicable au milieu de la crise donc
césarine transition c'est un peu son
temps mais c'est un tourniquet
ce qui est prévu en mai tri un peu
variable en fonction de ce que vous
mangez présence est prévu dans le texte
qui définit cas les charges c'est que
lorsque le principe de continuité
justifie maintien du titulaire il
demeure c'est prévu j'ai encore une
question avant qu'on reprenne les
questions nos collègues sur cette
question sanitaire
je voulais savoir si vos consultants ont
eu physiquement accès à la cellule
interministérielle de crise si c'est le
cas c'est ce qu'il y avait des
procédures de sécurité de vérification
qui ont été prévues au préalable parce
que d'après des informations que nous
avons recueillies vous avez par exemple
appuyer la taxe corde dans la synthèse
et la préparation de réunions de comités
claeys qui fut posée donc cette présence
ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
précisions sur ces points
merci monsieur le président donc le le
travail de l'équipe s'est faite au sein
du crdm où étaient basés ou est toujours
basée la cellule la cellule à la task
force un terme initial de gestion de la
crise et donc c'est là que l'équipe
l'équipe a joué son rôle
voilà avec après
un accès aux salles de réunion lorsqu'il
y avait des réunions mais c'est au sein
du crdm et là où se situe la taskforce
interministériel nous avons et ensuite
pour compléter la réponse est oui vous
avez eu accès et le deuxième partie de
la question c'est est ce qu'il y avait
des procédures particulières de sécurité
donc l'ensemble chacun des chacun des
consultants qui a été mobilisé a rempli
une déclaration d'intérêt
préalablement aux travaux et puis et
puis ensuite
l'accès au crd m est protégé par des
balles gens que l'équipe a eu a eu au
même titre que les agents qui
travaillent un badge
voilà
quelque chose pour préciser parce que le
crdm c'est le centre de réponse keystone
au niveau du ministère de la santé je
sais pas si c'est à ça que vous faites
référence monsieur le président mais
nous nous avons toujours travaillé dans
les locaux des missions de la santé
ils ne vont pas eu accès d si vous
voulez faire référence à des centres de
réponse de crise
est anticipée au conseil de défense
jamais non jamais là dessus il faut être
très clair notre rôle a été d'aider la
des équipes de ta sorte vaccinale qui
sont basés au sein du ministère de la
santé donc nos équipes étaient basés là
aux côtés des équipes du mystère de la
santé et travailler avec un badge et les
questions de sécurité applicables à
l'ensemble des salariés
et une dernière question sur la crise
sanitaire est ce que vous êtes encore
sur des missions liées à la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui
donc fin décembre le ministère nous a
nous a sollicités pour pour venir
apporter un appui complémentaire
de manière ponctuelle à la tasse force
dans le contexte de l'augmentation de la
pression épidémique et du rebond et pour
pour un appui très ponctuelles dans
l'accélération de la campagne de rappel
de manière à faire en sorte que chaque
français aient pu bénéficier d'un
créneau de rappel avant la fin janvier
donc on intervient maintenant mais
encore une fois de manière très
ponctuelle en appelons donc la fin de
l'illusion l'émission de la ferme les
yeux on se terminer les missions de
l'agent de liaison sont terminées les
missions de la koala ont appuyé la
parole celle
qui assume cette responsabilité doit
absolument et peut-être j'en profite
pour préciser que
systématiquement
nous avons travaillé à développer les
compétences des équipes au fur et à
mesure qu'elles se sont constitués
étoffé et 2 et 2 et d'assurer le transit
de transfert de tous les outils modèle
et c'est qu'on a construit
aux équipes de la task force et vos
équipes de spl donc il ya eu aussi ce
souci de faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des activités soient repris à leur
compte par par les agents publics
[Musique]